alain marty au bon soin remercie d'avoir
accepté notre association vous avez fait
paraître aux éditions max milo un récit
intitulé enfants mal placé c'est votre
histoire c'est l'histoire d'une
souffrance et d'une résilience la
souffrance c'est celle d'un enfant
maltraité la résilience c'est celle d'un
éducateur social c'est-à-dire que vous
aider des enfants qui ont été qu ils
sont dans la situation qui a été la
vôtre
quand vous étiez enfant et même tout
enfant puisque vous avez été placé dès
18 mois dans une famille d'accueil et
comment vous qualifier cette expérience
dans la famille d'accueil c'est une
enfance maltraitée vous avez été un
enfant maltraité moralement et
physiquement est ce que ça vous convient
comme définition c'est plus compliqué
c'est un peu plus compliqué alors oui il
y avait énormément de maltraitance j'ai
été placé à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
dès mon plus jeune âge j'ai vécu voilà
des violences physiques des violences
morales j'ai vécu voilà le fouet les
coups de pied mais il ya eu aussi des
moments de partage et c'est pour ça que
c'était un peu difficile de sortir de de
cet environnement et ça a été très long
et très compliqué pour moi de me rendre
compte de tout ce qui avait pu se passer
parce que j'étais assez
j'ai été manipulé quand j'étais enfant
et aujourd'hui est ce que vous entendez
par manipuler c'est une faisait du
chantage on expliquer ma mère avait été
placé en fait dans cette famille
d'accueil là quand j'étais quand elle
est un peu plus jeune
et quand je puis quand j'ai commencé à
comprendre et à poser des questions sur
ma mère on m'expliquait que je devais
remercier cette famille d'accueil là
parce que j'étais placé grâce à ma mère
et qui en fait ils s'étaient engagés par
rapport à elle à un premier duc et voilà
et donc quand il y avait ces
maltraitances larmes
il y avait déjà ce premier point et
derrière on m'expliquait que si je
commence à parler à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ou à dénoncer ce qui pouvait
se passer on a les mains levées de cette
famille qui se disait aimante et on
allait me mettre dans une autre famille
d'accueil qui allait me faire manger
avec les chiens qu'ils allaient
m'enfermer dans la cave qui allaient
voilà me battre ou alors aller dans des
foyers où on ne volerai mes affaires en
blu ray de l'argent enfin voilà où je
serais passé comme
un enfant victime au final ce con mais
non c'est dans une autre réalité si je
partais je vivais dans cette famille
d'accueil l'a donc il ya des souffrances
physiques quand même très sérieuse vous
êtes arrivé d'être de rester une journée
attaché sur une chaise parce que vous
aviez pris un morceau de pain il ya la
souffrance morale parce que vous n'étiez
pas traité comme les autres enfants
puissent les menaces dont vous faites
état mais vous avez l'air de vouloir
introduire quand même des nuances ce
n'est pas une enfance entièrement placée
sous le signe de la maltraitance
il y en a eu énormément mais il ya aussi
des bons moments cette famille d'accueil
la avait avait des origines espagnoles
et du coup nous emmener en espagne tous
les étés où j'ai pu faire des rencontres
magnifiques j'ai pu découvrir ce que
vous pouvez vivre un enfant dit lambda
donc jouer pouvoir développer son
imaginaire ce genre de choses et c'est
une famille qui m'a pas complètement
fermé j'avais le droit d'aller à l'école
j'appelle pas d'aller au collège
oui c'est bête c'est des fondamentaux
mais
c'est que tout le monde n'a pas accès à
ça aujourd'hui et à 15 ans vous vous
retrouvez à la porte de cette série oz
et placé en foyer
la famille d'accueil est tombé gravement
malade et pendant des années je les ai
soutenus dans la maladie ou voilà j'ai
dû l'accompagner à agir et à laver des
poches ou c'est moi qui les ai changé ce
genre de choses il se voyait mourir elle
m'a dit bon voilà tu vas être placé tu
reviendras 18 ans c'est là où j'ai
atterri
alors c'est pas foyer cemex maison
d'enfants à caractère social oui et là
j'ai découvert ce que c'était de vivre
et non de survivre mais quand vous avez
été placés vous n'étiez pas exactement
un foyer mais pour vous c'était un
soulagement ou un arrachement quand même
les trois premiers jours où je suis
arrivé sur cette structure je les ai
passées enfermé voilà ça a été très
difficile parce que pour moi c'était ma
famille est donc m'enlever de cette
famille mais par la suite j'ai découvert
ce que c'était de pouvoir aller faire un
foot avec les copains du foyer les
éducateurs était quand même assez
bienveillant on pouvait changer on jouer
au baby foot il y avait une dame qui
s'occupait de notre linge et qui
m'expliquait comment on faisait de
machine à laver
tous ces petits moments tous ces petits
détails de la vie quotidienne je les ai
appris avec bienveillance et du coup
j'ai appris à m'ouvrir appris à me
développer en tant qu'adolescent et
voilà ça a été dit je vais commencer à
vivre ne viviez pas avant non non je
pense que c'était de la survie je
prenais énormément sur moi je savais que
quelque chose n'allait pas mais je ne
m'exprimais pas je ne savais pas comment
l'exprimer
alors que ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est déjà votre histoire les
douloureuses ont longtemps et puis on va
vous poser des questions pour préciser
tout ça mais en faisant cette enquête
vous découvrez en fait que le placement
c'est une tradition familiale
si j'ose dire c'est que votre mère a été
placée et votre grand mère aussi
moi je savais pas que c'était possible
comment est-ce qu'on peut être placé de
mère en fille et deux filles en fils
c'est une grande question à quand le
social et qui commencent à émerger
mais c'est vrai que dans ma situation
personnelle voilà quand j'ai débuté les
recherches et un an et demi avec le
début de l'écriture de ce livre où j'ai
commencé à me questionner sur la vie de
ma mère je les fais avec
avec mon frère content on a on a poussé
un peu les portes on a retrouvé tout
l'entourage de mammeri cela ou qu'on a
découvert donc toute son existence de
placement ensuite on a découvert que la
grand mère avait été placé et que ça
venait de l'arrière-grand-mère arrière
grand mère que j'ai rencontré yann moix
où j'ai réussi à retrouver sa trace
ce qui me ce qui est difficile c'est de
se dire voilà l'héritage que pourrait
avoir un enfant lambda c'est une maison
une voiture un téléphone jean sérien de
l'argent ou autre chose ou des belles
valeurs moi j'ai eu un héritage de
placement et les questions qui
mériteraient d'être posées je pense
qu'aujourd'hui dans le travail social
c'est comment faire pour empêcher
justement ce type de situation de se
reproduire c'est qu'un enfant qui est
placé comment on peut briser la chaîne
et lui permettre de construire lui sa
propre famille 100 kg est justement
d'accompagnement éducatif heures
derrière lui je lui ai dit vous êtes
devenu éducateur spécialisé ce que ça a
été très tôt une voie vers laquelle vous
vous êtes orienté une évidence pour vous
c'est venu chemin faisant
eh ben pour moi c'est impossible de
travailler dans le social parce que
j'avais été placé donc j'avais j'avais
les yeux un peu fermé par rapport à ça
mais j'ai eu la chance grâce à une
éducatrice de passer le bafa et g j'ai
terminé à vanier des jeunes sur
différents séjours de vacances sur des
structures pour adolescents et en fait
je me suis questionnée sur la manière
d'accompagner ans avec des compétences
aller plus loin que simplement
l'animation traditionnelle et un jour
j'ai une copine qui était ma collègue
qui me regardent et qui me disent à
cannes tu n'es pas tu n'es pas directeur
tué éducateurs et je sais pas ça m'a
ouvert des yeux et à partir de ce moment
je me suis dit en fait je vais pas faire
éducateurs comme ça pourrait dit où on
va faire un transfert on va chercher à
combler quelque chose en faisant ce
travail mais je vais le faire parce que
j'ai envie d'avoir des compétences et de
pouvoir accompagner toutes ces personnes
qui ont besoin de de gens pour les
soutenir
je vais je vais laisser les chroniqueurs
poser les questions qu'ils souhaitent
mais il ya quand même quelque chose je
pense qu'il aura sauté aux yeux comme
ils ont sauté au mien c'est que vous
êtes très
ouvert très souriant et c'est très
étrange de voir cette cette bonne nature
que vous avez quand on est passé par
autant de souffrances et quand en plus
on découvre que cette souffrance vient
de loin dans la famille qu'elle remonte
jusqu'à la grand mère ce que vous avez
toujours eu ce caractère qui vous a
permis de surmonter les épreuves où vous
avez été un temps tri si vous avez
réussi à surmonter
j'ai appris à cacher mes émotions plutôt
difficile à ne pas les montrer et très
rapidement je me suis rendu compte que
d'être souriante d'être dynamics à
apporter aux autres donc j'ai fait très
tôt adopté
je sais pas comment dire c'est cette
caractéristique et j'ai toujours voulu
cacher le fait que j'étais placé et des
violences que j'avais pu avoir donc j'ai
un peu menti toute ma vie sur justement
ce passé difficile et en fait c'est
devenu naturel de sourire et justement
d'essayer d'apporter quelque chose aux
gens
grâce aux personnes que j'ai pu
rencontrer il ya eu assmann que je cite
dans livia ulliott il ya eu boukheir par
toutes ces personnes qui m'ont soutenu
et qui montrent comment dire accueilli à
bras ouverts son jugement et je le dis à
la fin de mon livre la vie c'est une
question de rencontres et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on traverse sociale et en
tant que personne dans la société dans
laquelle on est on peut s'appuyer sur
les gens qu'on a autour de soi pour
faire face aux difficultés et ça je le
défends je le défend énormément